liste non féminin désignant une suite
d'éléments inscrire les uns en dessous
des autres en matière électorale c'est
un peu comme pour vos courses sans liste
vous ne pouvez rien faire si ce n'est
erré comme une âme en peine au rayon
fromage au bureau de vote numéro 7 sans
pouvoir remplir votre panier
ou bien les urnes dans un scrutin bien
mais c'est un peu le caddie qui relie la
ménagère à la crise hier mais sans les
petites roulettes et le siège en france
sur le devant lieuran ifpi quoi le
milieu de l'électeur et du candidat
inscrit chacun de son côté de la moine
sur une liste pour figurer sur la liste
des électeurs comme sur la liste des
candidats
il faut avoir 18 ans si vous êtes
électeur rien ne vous oblige à être
candidat en revanche pour être candidat
il est fortement recommandé d'être
électeur un peu comme les caisses panier
ou vous scannez vous même vos courses
pour les municipales 2014 date limite de
péremption de dépôt des candidatures
le 6 mars et cette fois-ci chaque liste
de candidats doit être paritaires un
candidat doit suivre ont précédé une
candidate ou inversement
sauf pour les communes de moins de 1000
habitants où là il est encore permis que
monsieur assiste au conseil municipal
pendant que madame elle ira faire les
courses